hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video
and today for a titanfall 2 we're gonna
be discussing the best of beginning
loadout for when you start the game and
when you start to get a little bit into
it like around level 10 15 ish now so
let's get into that so the first thing
the the first part of the loadout that
you want to look at is the kit and the
abilities the number one thing you
always want to stick with is stim or
cloak but in this instance if you're a
new player you want to do stim
yes cloaking keep you invisible but stim
gives you that extra speed boost and if
you're dying quickly seeing is you're
new to this you won't know how to play
stem will give you increased or increase
your health regeneration faster so you
can live longer and figure out how to
play this game better the weapon of
choice that you want to stick with is
either the are 201 carbine or the car
SMG the car SMG is a good starter weapon
for anyone that's like into SMGs and
it's kind of fast pace but the basic
weapon you want to stick with is the are
201 terms or grenades you want to stick
with the Gert the frag grenade like
always it's basic it's good for the
secondary weapon I chose an anti-tank
weapon or an anti-titan weapon no no
secondary pistol
seeing as you're probably going to be
playing more bounty hunt and nutrition
you're gonna need to take out those
Titans I chose the mg L rocket launcher
or the mg L grenade launcher I apologize
it is the best starting weapon in the
game it's better than the charge rifle
it sells more damage in the charge rifle
and then the charge rope you have to
charge up and those change you could die
while doing it it's just a hassle the
two other kits you want to bring our
kill reports you can see where the
enemies are when they die and fast regen
to get even more health back when you
reach in stacking on top of stem the
execution it doesn't really matter the
attachments you can just go along with
that you're a beginner it's alright
but once you get to rank 1015 you want
to switch to the hemlock the hemlock has
been considered super overpowered and it
is kind of broken in some instances that
I've seen so I can definitely tell you
that the hemlock is a very good weapon
to get when you get to it and like
halfway through the game other than that
this is the best beginning loadout for
pilots so I hope you all did enjoy I'm
doing this for most of the Christmas
moves that have gotten their game
yesterday so good luck to all of you who
got it and if you want to see if you
want to see more of my content like that
or hit that's absurd hit the subscribe
button hit the like button comment your
opinion on some of this stuff guys and
I'll see you in a bit peace out